I either have 500 subscribers or five
million subscribers but I'm gonna give
you my platform for up to five minutes
so you could take up to five minutes or
not to talk about whatever you want
whatever is on your mind just yeah
starting now
starting now I don't know what to talk
about what am I supposed to talk about
we were just talking about like being
good to one another right right now and
I was just thinking like earlier you
know I'm selling these roses and people
like with their like high-end careers
and jobs you know they think they're
better than you because they have a
degree or something any you know
whatever else but really like but
matters like your your character your
soul and how rich it is the way you
speak to people I think the way you deal
with people you know when I see those
type of people are trying to forget
about it because that right there like
with the attitudes and stuff like that
that's petty crap and what I'm trying to
focus on right now in my life is just to
like
Oh what is it that I should really care
about what should i what should I focus
and like what should what should get me
mad actually once you let all that go
positivity you just come in
and you can just naturally catch it
instead
walking on eggs oh you know
to say recently a couple of my friends
and I were in Vegas for the route 91 and
it was amazing for the first couple of
days you saw every bit of good and every
bit of evil all at the same time
luckily my friends and I got out safely
or shaken up I do pray for all of the
families and everyone that was there
should never have to experience that but
I believe that as a result of how
everybody treats people and so take one
day at a time live your life and do what
you want to do but be kind to everyone
hybl a PA was full of hate and I also
pray for his soul
and I hope that we can all just well
have a bond with each other and just go
from here
spread love love is the answer
love is the answer for everything and if
we all had love for one another we would
have no ink and no umm jealousy no
racism no rudeness that's what I have to
say
thanks for watching another episode if
you haven't already it would mean a lot
if you subscribe to my channel like this
video share it a couple episodes of
friends and help support my project
thank you
[Music]